well what tends to happen is one domino
falls and then the others start to fall
as well
last night i got word that the jaguars
and former ohio state and florida coach
urban meyer are moving toward getting a
deal done now nothing is done until it's
done we learned that three years ago
with josh mcdaniels not leaving the
patriots for the cults
but the chatter among the nfl coaching
fraternity as of late last night
was it's moving toward urban meyer
paired up with interim jaguars gm trent
bauke
as the new gm setting the table for
meyer with meyer in charge of the
football operation
that could be happening pretty much at
any time and with meyer you never know
what's ultimately going to happen
someone i trust says i think it's going
to get right up to the brink and he's
not going to take it and we've seen that
before bill parcells
did that to tampa bay 19 years ago where
everything is pointing in one direction
and when it's time to put pen to paper
the guy just can't do it just like josh
mcdaniels
although the difference here is they
don't have to wait for urban meyer they
can find out now
are you putting pen to paper so until he
does it's not done
but there's a sense that that's where
it's moving well i it seems like anybody
you talk to that
yes that's where it's going i mean
obviously that's jacksonville's number
one spot
urban myers you know seems to be
flirting with it you know tremendously
and
and it makes a lot of sense from every
aspect all together
but yeah i mean i wouldn't be shocked to
see it go either way
you know like you said or urban meyer
urban meyer
has a track record of being worn out and
stressed out and
man how many shows have i watched of him
and his family talking about those
issues after a few years
and college football is a pain in the
butt nfl
like you talked about yesterday when we
were having the saban conversation and
all those type of things
it's a different animal it really is it
might not be as the pain in the butt
because you don't have to recruit all
all year round but the intensity and the
stress of the job
is greater and the scrutiny and just
constantly under the microscope is
greater than any college place you can
you can go to so that's where i would be
worried about urban meyer as we go into
the future can
can he hang in there for more than two
or three years and and really finish the
job and build something there in
jacksonville
one more twist on all this that that
could be very telling moving forward
you know anytime anyone says the jaguars
are going to play more games in london
or may move to london at some point the
response has always been
shot khan the owner of the team is
trying to make major investments in the
infrastructure around the stadium
lot j is something we've been hearing
about for a while yeah shot khan spoke
about it back in october
that basically we need to have a vision
for jacksonville we need to
improve the the overall perception of
jacksonville we need to we need to
revitalize and we need to expand and we
need to do this and we need to do
jacksonville city council voted down lot
jay last night it needed 152.7 million
in public investment and it wasn't even
a close
vote in jacksonville's city council so
jacksonville doesn't share shad khan's
vision for what needs to be done
around the stadium and that could be the
first domino
that leads toward a split schedule with
london or who knows what else
those are dynamics that urban meyer
needs to fully understand before he puts
pen to paper
and those are dynamics that maybe trevor
lawrence understands before he says
don't draft me jacksonville jaguars and
look folks i'm not
advocating anything here but for years
now
i've been led to believe this lot j
thing
is the ultimate proof that shad khan is
committed
to jacksonville while jacksonville isn't
committed to lot j
that that has to change the broader
calculation chris
i would think so to a degree i you know
also though i guess
i i wouldn't be too critical in reading
it it is a pandemic
you know states cities they're they're
in they said it's but it's done it's
done no
chance it's not never going to happen
pulling the plug on it wow
they're pulling the plug on it yeah then
that would scare me okay that would
scare me
a lot if i'm a jaguars fan that you
might lose a few more games or who knows
what the hell happens from here
look at the end of the day these
football teams
are businesses and there's a little
sleight of hand involved where they
don't want the average fan to think it's
a business because it makes you jaded
and it makes you cynical and
that they want us all to be starry-eyed
and think that there's some greater
thing going on you know it's it's
dollars and cents
and you want to make as most as much
money as you can
in return on the investment you've made
in the team and if you think you can
make more money somewhere else
especially if the local government is
going to start telling you no
that's when you start looking for local
governments that may tell you yes
and that's why we've seen a reshuffling
of the deck with several franchises in
recent years
so it's just something to keep an eye on
if you are
a fan of the nfl a jaguars fan or
our friends in the uk and ireland you
may be getting more jaguars games and
a couple of years ago you may have
groaned at that possibility
with trevor lawrence you may be
delighted by that possibility
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports